as it nears the supermassive black hole
at our galaxy's heart the probe is at
the mercy of one of the most fundamental
forces in the universe
a force with the power to twist space
and send the probe traveling through
time
gravity is something incredibly
commonplace we're always dropping things
you know we're not flying off the
surface of the earth it's a part of our
lives for the moment that we're born but
it turns out it's a very mysterious and
deep part of the universe when something
has mass it has the ability to bend
space
before Einstein's theory of general
relativity scientists imagined space as
a stage set on which the action played
out
Einstein's genius was to realize that
space itself was an actor in the drama
we tend to think of space is just the
stuff around us but it's it's actually
kind of a thing it has a physical
component to it like a fabric like a
sheet in empty space light travels in a
straight line but place something
massive like our Sun on the fabric of
space and its immense gravity warps
space as light travels past the Sun it's
straight path curves the light bends not
because the light bends but the space in
which the light is travelling curves
itself this is why our probes trajectory
is curving the black hole's gravity is
warping the fabric of space everything
that travels through this curved space
must follow a curved path including
light the amazing thing is that not only
does gravity warp the light into the
black hole light coming from farther
away gets bent around it and so you
could see this shimmering distortion
into the stars in the background as a
black hole moved in front it would
almost be like taking a piece of glass
and moving it across the star field
and it's not just space that the black
hole is bending
time is warping too so if we send a
probe going into a black hole from our
point of view we see it falling in and
we see it falling in more and more
slowly because it's clock is ticking
slower and slower and slower that's a
bizarre concept and it's really hard to
wrap our brains around but that is what
the math and physics are telling us we
experience time as hours minutes and
seconds it seems straightforward but
time is relative it changes depending on
where you are it seems to the viewer
that this shot has a picture of a moment
in time in a moment in space but it's
actually not a moment in space in a
moment in time it's spread out in space
because there's some depth of field
behind me but it's also spread out in
time because the light from the
whiteboard behind me left the whiteboard
a little bit earlier than the light from
my face so when you see an image you're
really seeing something that's spread
out in space and time
so when gravity distorts space it also
alters time
change the amount of gravity you're
experiencing and time shifts to